recently in the British Journal the
guardian an article was published under
the title do we need a new theory of
evolution we learn of great
chaos a battle with quote the weight of
a theological
[Music]
Schism we're told there is a revolution
led by a neglected group of
underdogs the article describes those to
oppress these Brave Rebels as quote high
priests who dominate and ostracize all
those who dare question the quote
evolutionary
Orthodoxy it's tasm
then well as you might imagine it turns
out that the guardian is totally foolish
on this one you can click the little
play button over late here or find a
link in the video description for my
full review